why is it never been a documentary about
the dark side of Disney World they are
so powerful Disney is so [ __ ]
powerful has there ever been a dock have
you ever seen anything I mean maybe I'm
wrong
I think Banksy did that thing on it what
did he do he went in there to the the
little children one that it's a small
world after all this small world and he
did the he dressed a guy and a gwaan
tottemo Bay outfit and he hung him from
over like a rollercoaster he was like
hanging Guantanamo Bay prisoner and he
did it with that uh that mr. brainwash
Americans don't notice they think it's
great
look there's a Gitmo prisoner this is a
good rock I thought this ride was for
[ __ ] but it's good I thought a small
world was for [ __ ] I fought my wife
body no we were gonna see Muslims get
hung this is great
that'll make it the most popular ride in
the whole [ __ ] place
do you not they love it yeah Banksy hung
this Guantanamo Bay yeah
it was the longest line in the whole
park they're hanging Muslims in there
it's worth the wait